[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week-end on va parler
actualités mais aussi loisirs d'ailleurs
voici les titres de ce vendredi 22
janvier
l'actualité et c'est évidemment la mise
en orbite du nano satellites conçus par
le laboratoire atmosphères milieux
observations spatiales de latmos située
à guyancourt
il aura lieu samedi 23 janvier à 15
heures 24
15h40 pardon nous en parlerons avec
notre journaliste bixente mais rien
senti steban est notre invité mustapha
meftah principal investigateur
scientifique de la mission
uv excuse ça tu nous vous proposerons
aussi les idées sorties et loisirs de
célia gars tsongo avec de la cuisine ou
encore du cinéma avec un hommage à jean
pierre bacri enfin un nouveau rendez
vous dans votre 7,8 week end vincent
couronne créateur du site internet les
surligneurs décrypte les déclarations
des personnalités publiques et
politiques
aujourd'hui il peut y pose pardon la
question qui peut commander les vaccins
et aussi le résumé de l'actualité de la
semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme je vous le disais en titre
l'actualité c'est le lancement d'une
nano satellites conçus par le
laboratoire atmosphères milieux
observations spatiales située à
guyancourt
il devait être mise en orbite
aujourd'hui vendredi 22 janvier
ce sera finalement demain samedi 23
janvier cela nos satellites du latmos
est actuellement à bord de la navette
falcon in space 2 space x pour nous en
parler bixente mais rien senti steben
bonsoir bonsoir oui comme vous venez de
le dire et l'honore lui à ce que ça du
latmos de guyancourt ne partira que
demain et pour cause des dernières
vérifications de sécurité ont dû être
effectués au deuxième étage de la fusée
qu'est ce que la notion ubs qui s'attend
c'est un nano satellites un peu plus
grand qu'un rubicube destiné à l'étude
du climat et du soleil l'objectif c'est
de quantifier le réchauffement de la
planète
il a pour cela deux fonctionnalités
premièrement capter les radiations
provenant du soleil et en seconde manche
mesurer la quantité de cette énergie
renvoyé par notre planète avec ces
données on pourrait avoir une petite
idée de ce qui reste sur la terre et
calculé la quantité de gaz à effet de
serre
pour rappel certaines simulations
prévoit une augmentation de 7 degrés
celsius d'ici à 2100 c'est donc
l'urgence climatique qui a motivé la
mission à savoir avoir une meilleure
compréhension pour mieux agir il faut
insister sur le fait que ce satellite
n'est qu'une démonstration
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir vérifier la
capacité du latmos a envoyé un nano
satellites pour ensuite envoyer une
constellation de satellites identiques
pour couvrir une surface plus large et
avoir plus de données alors comment se
déroule cette mission précisément du cnt
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
l'ue est ce qu sa tête à bord de la
navette de lancement falcon line comme
vous l'avez rappelé c'est une mission de
spaces qui a à son bord environ 130
satellites plus ou moins gros c'est un
record falcone a déjà décollé ce
mercredi 20 janvier mais une partie de
la fusée est réutilisé et repart demain
à 15h40 space x finalement n'est qu'un
prestataire pour le latmos les deux
laboratoires ont été en relation le long
de la mission pour la coordination
lubezki sat sera mise en orbite
une heure après le décollage et il sera
lâché en orbite basse soit à 700
kilomètres du sol
il faut souligner que la majorité voire
l'intégralité des tests ont été
effectués à guyancourt compte tenu des
conditions sanitaires
il fallait vérifier notamment si le
petit satellite résister aux vibrations
aux radiations mais aussi à la
température puisque dans l'espace il
fait moins de 169 de rennes en effet
alors dans ce cas du coup pourquoi lui
vs kull les mots sont choisis un
satellite amène aux satellites plus tôt
car c'est normal et bien le nano
satellites a ses avantages 1 il est
d'abord moins cher à produire
la mission uvsq usap n'a coûté que 2
millions d'euros ça paraît beaucoup dit
comme ça mais c'est très peu pour une
mission spatiale j'imagine il est
également plus rapide à construire
puisque le projet a débuté en 2018 ça
dépanne également un gros problème de
débris spatiaux puisqu'on entend souvent
que l'espace est devenue une poubelle
avec les nano satellites ce sont moins
de volume donc moins de déchets perdu
ces satellites sont généralement équipés
de systèmes de désorbitation ou
autrement appelé fin de vie pour ne pas
polluer l'espace eh bien merci bixente
d'avoir été avec nous et pour toutes ces
précisions
et pour continuer à parler de ce sujet
notre entretien réalisé quelques heures
avant cette émission avec mustapha
meftah scientifique du latmos regarder
bonjour mustapha meftah vous êtes le
principal instigateur scientifique de la
mission uvsq us at du latmos qui est le
laboratoire je le rappelle atmosphères
milieux observations spatiales
c'est hébergé en partie à l'observatoire
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
vous faites donc partie de l'équipe qui
a conçu ce nano satellites
concrètement alors quelle a été votre
implication alors mon application
bonjour madame d'abord une application
c'était de mettre en oeuvre une idée une
idée scientifique programme est dédié à
l'observation de la terre et aux
relations solitaire et ensuite nos
travaux c'est d'essayer de trouver des
fonds des financements de mettre en
oeuvre toute une stratégie pour pouvoir
développer une mission sociale de a à z
donc c'est à dire de la définition
jusqu'à la mise en orbite d'un satellite
et de l'exploitation scientifique de ces
données combien de personnes travaillent
avec vous sur ce projet alors sur ce
projet on a été plus d'une quinzaine de
personnes avec des fonctions différentes
et des corps de métiers différents
quels sont les tests qui ont été
réalisés dans l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines est ce que par
exemple la nos satellites a été
construit ici même à guyancourt
ou bien est ce que les tests ont été
réalisés au sein du latmos alors en
général nous avons une partie des
composants qui sont achetés à
l'extérieur on travaille avec des
industriels
on essaye au maximum de fonctionner avec
des industriels du territoire et ensuite
la majeure partie est tout tout
l'intégration du satellite a été fait
dans nos locaux donc ici à guyancourt
les essais d'environnement ont ici été
fait sur place certains tests ont été
réalisés à toulouse donc au cnes
l'agencé spatiale française ou à l'onera
mais la majeure partie des
développements été réalisé sous
responsabilité du laboratoire et
l'intérêt majeur au but de la période
particulière que nous traversons c'était
d'avoir une approche qui nous permettait
de mettre en oeuvre justement une forme
de réappropriation d'autonomie
d'indépendance et nous avons essayé de
mettre au maximum une mise en avant du
terrain
ouah donc on l'a bien compris mise en
avant du territoire beaucoup de choses
réalisées quand même au sein du latmos a
accueilli en cours qu'est ce qu'apporte
justement finalement l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines à
cette mission
alors ce qu'apporte universités déjà un
c'est la matière grise à savoir des
cerveaux des personnes qui vont mettre
en oeuvre une stratégie scientifique
dans notre cas de figure une stratégie
d'observation de la terre en lien avec
le climat pour pouvoir travailler donc
sur l'orientation future du climat
notamment sur les décennies qui viennent
voir consolider des modèles des
universitaires les modélisateurs met en
oeuvre des modèles et pour pouvoir
consolider ses modèles nous devrons
aussi développé des instruments pour
nous ce qu'il y à vraiment très
important c'est que à la fois donc le
scientifique c'est notre travail doit
être à la fois combinés d'une approche
au d'études théoriques et aussi
d'observation donc on doit mettre en
oeuvre une stratégie pour développer des
satellites pour pouvoir observer mieux
comprendre les interactions avec le
milieu et l'atmosphère et enfin un
troisième paramètre c'est agir et
proposer des solutions alors le
lancement du nano satellites et de la
mission du coup vs q7 a été décalé
plusieurs fois le lancement était
initialement prévu en décembre 2020 quel
en a été la raison est ce qu'il ya
plusieurs raisons à ces décalages assez
successifs alors c'est systématique dans
notre façon de travailler vous savez un
lancement c'est toujours particulier
donc la particularité de ce lancement
c'est un lancement qui va être réalisée
par space x et le nom de la fusée ses
falcon 9
et donc on est sur un cas particulier
donc c'est un second sacre tiers
c'est-à-dire un transporteur de plus
d'une centaine de satellites qui va être
mis en orbite pour ce lancement
particulier donc les événements sont
particulier dans le sens où il peut y
avoir à un moment des problèmes ou des
soucis par rapport à certains
fournisseurs de satellites comme nous
donc on décale près légèrement et donc
plus de 100 satellite à intégrer sur un
seul sens lors spurs est une prouesse
technologique
donc comme vous pouvez vous en douter
assister à une fin d'artifice dans
l'espace il ya beaucoup de pyrotechnie
et ensuite il peut y arriver à un moment
des petits imprévus typiquement je peux
vous raconter une anecdote on devait un
moment partir ce 14 janvier initialement
2021 et à un moment des chaînes
pyrotechniques ont été activés deux
satellites ont été éjectés par accident
donc ça c'est pour c'est pour cette
raison aussi qu'on peut avoir même
jusqu'au dernier moment un décalage
alors aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
phase où évidemment il faut aussi de
bonnes conditions météorologiques
donc ces paramètres restent quand même
complexe elle vous parlez de spe 6 juste
avant comment s'est passée justement les
relations avec ses 6 alors les relations
explicites sont très bonne on a en face
de nous une compagnie qui est une image
excellente par rapport à ce que l'on ne
met en avant aujourd'hui c'est à dire le
new space une nouvelle stratégie pour
développer le spatial
ensuite dans notre cas de figure on
passe par un intermédiaire pour gérer
nos affaires de lancement pour la simple
et bonne raison que pour pouvoir
discuter en direct avec space x et
mettre en orbite des dispositifs il faut
au moins un million d'euros de charges
utiles à mettre en orbite dans notre cas
de figure pour avoir un ordre d'idée on
est aux alentours de 100 mille euros le
kg qui doit être mis en orbite
eh bien merci pour toutes ces précisions
et d'avoir été avec nous le staff à
meftah
[Applaudissements]
l'actualité de la semaine c'est nicolas
d'andry qui nous la résume en 78
secondes
[Musique]
cette semaine a commencé avec la
poursuite du déploiement de la
vaccination dans les yvelines neuf
centres ont commencé leur activité
parmi ces sites le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et un centre
social et culturel à saint germain en
laye d'une vaccination ouverts depuis le
lundi 18 janvier aux personnes de plus
de 75 ans ce jour-là nadia ministre
délégué à la ville s'est rendu à poissy
un déplacement dans le cadre du projet
de cité éducative déployés sur la
commune objectif développer
l'accompagnement éducatif des enfants
dans les quartiers prioritaires elles
pourraient soutenir l'activité des
commerçants les soldes d'hiver ont
commencé mercredi 20 janvier
la veille les magasins se préparer dans
un contexte particulier avec la crise
sanitaire
la règle c'est l'adaptation des horaires
par rapport au couvre-feu et la
diminution des stocks face à la baisse
anticipée des ventes
mercredi c'était aussi le lancement des
inscriptions sur la plateforme parcours
sup
objectif trouver la formation en études
supérieures pour la rentrée en septembre
2021 pour aider les lycéens dans leur
choix le salon de l'étudiant ouvert de
manière virtuelle le jeudi 21 et se
tient jusqu'au samedi 23 janvier à
distance
[Musique]
après cette semaine bien chargée quoi de
mieux que de se détendre le week-end
comme chaque vendredi célia gars de son
go nous propose ses idées sorties et
loisirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci léonore et cette semaine nous
allons parler cuisine avec le couvre-feu
à 18h plus aucune raison de ne pas se
mettre aux fourneaux le soir alors que
manger lors du souper
le ch la chef soraya mais hour a
concocté une recette typiquement
libanaise pour l'occasion une soupe de
lentilles aux blettes qu'on peut goûter
mélanie poké et pierre gau reiber
regardez aujourd'hui je vous présente
une recette de mon pays d'origine le
liban
c'est l'hiver il fait froid alors rien
de tel qu'une soupe pour se réchauffer
on commence donc par couper un gros
oignon des et on le fait bondir d'un 4
cuillères à soupe d'huile d'olive on
ajoute ensuite 300 g de lentilles sèche
et si verdot le repas du soir c'est bien
qu'il soit à troquera voilà parce que
avoir eu un bol alimentaire grave va
ralentir la vidange gastrique c'est à
dire ça va ralentir ou fait la digestion
pour nous c'est le moment de passer à la
pomme de terre
cette pomme de terre coupées aux tout
petits cubes qu'on ne sentira quasiment
plus à la fin et pour les saveurs on
assaisonne avec 2 cuillères à soupe de
cumin et une seule de 4 épices pendant
que ça mijote en x de la coriandre
fraîche avec 4 gousses d'ail ont fait
revenir à la casserole la moitié de la
préparation avec un peu d'huile d'olive
et quand les auteurs montrent up tôt
dans la marmite notre set est quasiment
terminée la soupe cuit doucement je n'ai
plus qu'à préparer les blettes légumes
d'hiver par excellence on ne garde que
la partie verte couper les feuilles en
lamelles attention par contre les ligues
ne doivent rejoindre la marmite que dix
minutes avant de la fin de cuisson des
lentilles donc là elle associe à la fois
les féculents avec les lentilles et
légumes
tout ça sous forme de potages on casse
ça va hydrater le corps pour la touche
finale un peu de sel et du jus de citron
selon votre envie ajouté sur le dessus
le reste de la coriandre et voilà la
soupe qui réchauffe aussi bien les corps
que les coeurs et qui fait voyager loin
sans avoir besoin d'acheter des billets
didier un air de famille ou encore le
sens de la fête l'auteur acteur et
scénariste jean pierre bacri nous a
quitté ce lundi 18 janvier justine
brasier bonjour vous avez voulu lui
rendre hommage
jean pierre bacri et s'imposer comme une
figure majeure du cinéma français
exactement celle yale a conquis le coeur
de beaucoup de français en effet l'
éternel râleur au grand coeur si je peux
l'appeler comme ça même si c'est une
étiquette qu'il n'aimait pas trop
finalement et pourtant c'est ce qui a
fait se distinguer dans beaucoup de
films et on s'attache assez facilement
je dois dire à sept personnages un peu
bougon
je vous propose de regarder un exemple
avec le sens de la fête d'olivier
nakache et eric toledano sorti en 2007
jour vous m'avez envoyé merci c'est pour
ton gentil massage tu vois cette voie là
ça s'est sûr de facteurs en plus
je trouve pas les ponctuations je le
trouve avec dd tout débit la ccl rond
jaune qui a été tire la langue avec des
lunettes de soleil est mêlé sa voix
laisse aller et c'est un artiste qui
avait un certain franc-parler et aussi
bien dans la réalité que dans ses rôles
et elle condamne souvent la bêtise
humaine célia voici un extrait assez
représentatif de cette attitude c'est un
passage du film cuisine et dépendances
sortie en 93 qu'est ce que la majorité
finalement alors que le rapport jamet
directeur enveloppe c'est tout mais
voilà c'est la majorité voilà laquelle
d'abord laquelle celles qui pensaient
que la terre était plate
celle qui le rétablir la peine de mort
telle qui chouine plume dans le cul
parce que c'est la mode laquelle
exactement le film est une adaptation de
la pièce de théâtre de 1991 qui a été co
écrite par jean pierre bacri et sa
partenaire au cinéma comme dans la vie
agnès jaoui le binôme s'est rencontré en
1987 ils ont acquis ensemble neuf films
parmi lesquels dont cuisine et
dépendances dont on vient de voir
l'extrait ou encore le goût des autres
et un air de famille et la réplique la
plus culte de jean pierre la crise est
alors beaucoup s'accorde à dire qu'elle
provient du film didier
2 alain chabat qui est sorti en 1997
c'est une comédie en fait dans laquelle
donc al-hasaba incarne un labrador qui
s'est transformé en humain et donc il a
des réactions de chiens donc parfois un
peu bizarre dans la réalité regardes et
tu veux pas quand tu vois quelqu'un il
faut pas d'entrée donc ça le change sur
le cul c'est important ça c'est très
important
on ne sent pas le cul quand on n'est pas
d'accord il nous aura bien fait rire en
tout cas les petits clins d'oeil au
département puisque jean pierre bacri
est passé dans les yvelines par
lisibilité aux blacks c'était en 1990 il
était venu précisément à à poissy et
archère plus pour en fait là le film la
tribu un film d'yves boisset donc pour
le tournage et puis il est aussi passé
par le théâtre du monde entier en 2016
pourrait jouer la pièce les femmes
savantes
merci beaucoup justin avec plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
continuer à pratiquer une activité
physique ou à faire de la cuisine malgré
le couvre-feu
la ville de magny-les-hameaux s'y engage
nous recevons donc aujourd'hui notre
invité bertrand aux lions à bonjour
bonjour vous êtes donc le maire de magny
les hameaux sur la page facebook de la
ville on peut voir des petites vidéos
sportives
d'abord qui les réalisent alors ce sont
les éducatrices et éducateurs sportifs
de la commune qui donc ils sont trois et
ils le proposent donc chaque semaine
différents exercices à faire chez soi
d'accord et donc justement quel sport
est pratiqué plusieurs sports peut-être
alors c'est du fitness de la remise en
forme ou du maintien en forme
le tout c'est que ces exercices peuvent
être facilement pratiqué à la maison ben
vous voyez là sur les images qui sont
qui sont proposées il y a besoin de peu
de matériel il y avait même des des
vidéos en ligne où on utilise tout
simplement une table et une chaise
voilà le tout c'est que tout le monde
puis ceux utilisés c'est ses
propositions ses explications pour
pouvoir pratiquer le sport de manière la
plus régulière possible dans le contexte
où on est et ses vidéos on peut les voir
sur facebook uniquement où il ya sur
d'autres plateformes alors sur facebook
et sur le site de la commune et il ya
des nouvelles choses donc qui sont
présentés tout simplement chaque semaine
on a aussi des actions qui ont été
menées vis-à-vis du public senior ou
bien sur des courtes qui avait lui aussi
une manière régulière
pour les inscrits à ses courbes il ya
une poursuite aussi en vidéoconférence
donc avec notamment sylvie d'adieu donc
responsable du service des sports qui
qui donne ses cours là le soir et qui
est donc en direct avec les inscrits
alors pourquoi vous réaliser toutes ces
petites vidéos
alors aujourd'hui le sport en salle
est interdit et il nous semble
particulièrement important que pour la
santé des habitants
on puisse continuer de proposer ses
activités tout le monde n'a pas
forcément beaucoup de matériel chez soi
d'où l'aspect simple aussi puisqu'on
peut finalement faire du sport assez
simplement en utilisant une chaise et on
dit souvent et encore plus actuellement
que le sport permet de maintenir en
forme permet aussi de lutter contre
certaines maladies de rester en bonne
santé plus longtemps et dans le contexte
a dit qu'elles ont des pensées aussi que
la pratique de l'activité physique
permet de réduire un certain nombre de
risques liés à l'épidémie est
actuellement aux le service jeunesse et
citoyenneté de la ville appelée aussi
cap'ados et est également très actif en
sur sa page facebook
voilà c'est en fait un petit peu tous
les les services se sont mis au fur et à
mesure à proposer des différentes
activités alors pour le service jeunesse
et citoyenneté
on est passé de recettes de tender's de
poulet de madeleine affaire à des à des
ateliers aussi des tuto pour pouvoir
fabriquer ses balles de jonglage et puis
à prendre finalement à jongler ou bien
encore il ya eu une recette un peu
particulière qui a été il semble un
savon nourrissons pour les mains dans le
contexte actuel encore voilà ça peut
être utile et ça permet de passer un
certain nombre de
deux messages d'abord qu'on peut
facilement faire de la cuisine chez soi
qu'on peut aussi facilement créer des
produits d'hygiène soi même ça permet
aussi de d'accompagner l'éducation à
l'autonomie et notamment à l usage de
moins de plastique par exemple est très
rapidement une dernière question est-ce
que vous avez deux nouvelles vidéos qui
vont être présentés
alors on continue toujours donc
d'alimenter avec des des vidéos sur le
sport un petit peu moins actuellement
sur la jeunesse puisque le service a
rouvert donc du coup il accueille de
nouveau les jeunes de la commune
directement dans les lieux en respectant
donc les protocoles sanitaires
par contre on engage un certain nombre
d'actions notamment dans le domaine de
la culture et on va avoir une première
retransmission qui va avoir lieu le
samedi 6 février à 20h30 qui sera le
concert de notre harmonie manie croise
donc qui ne peut pas avoir lieu en
direct on leur a permis d'accéder aux
salles pour faire leur leur leurs
répétitions et donc ça sera une première
et on espère pouvoir continuer de
proposer comme ça des activités pour
finalement belle occuper un peu aussi
les soirées de couvre-feu en trouvant de
la culture trouvant du sport au niveau
de magny les hameaux et puis ça permet
de continuer d'avoir du lien aussi avec
tout le monde puisque ça va nous fini
aussi par se lancer quelques défis merci
beaucoup
bertrand aux lions à d'avoir été notre
invité est le 7-8 week end se poursuit
avec eléonore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
pour refermer ce 7,8 week end un nouveau
rendez vous qu'on vous propose en
partenariat avec les surligneurs ce
collectif qui décrypte les déclarations
des personnalités publiques et
politiques
aujourd'hui retour sur qui peut
commander les vaccins en écoute vincent
couronne docteur en droit à l'université
versailles saint quentin et fondateur
des surligneurs
[Musique]
le
nombreux sont ceux qui depuis quelques
semaines l'information selon laquelle la
france avait pris un retard dans la
vaccination qui frôle le ridicule à côté
de ses voisins européens
nombreux sont ceux qui depuis tente de
comprendre pourquoi un tel retard jeudi
retard et pas rater car à en croire le
gouvernement
cette lenteur est voulue dans un pays où
la défiance à l'égard du vaccin dépasse
les 50%
mais il y en a un qui a une solution
c'est hervé morin le président de la
région normandie il a annoncé sur lci
que sa région était en négociations avec
un laboratoire pour ses propres doses de
vaccin jugeant qu'il faut vacciner le
plus massivement et le plus rapidement
possible pourquoi pas en effet mettre
les collectivités locales
au coeur du dispositif de vaccination
sauf qu'il ya un hic
et pour comprendre celui qu il faut
faire un peu d'histoire
remontons au grand de loi de
décentralisation de 1981
à l'époque l'état qui ne laisse que des
miettes de pouvoir aux communes et aux
départements décrète un big bang
territorial et dans ce flux de pouvoir
transférer aux collectivités
il y à la vaccination qui devient une
compétence des départements sauf que il
faut croire que l'expérience n'a pas été
concluante
treize ans plus tard en 2004 une autre
loi vient rendre à l'état ce qui lui
appartenait à l'origine il laisse
cependant au département la possibilité
de continuer à gérer ses campagnes de
vaccination mais seulement après une
convention signée avec lui à l'époque 59
départements ont fait ce choix
mais beaucoup ont depuis abandonné ce
rôle trop coûteux dans un contexte de
crise des finances publiques locales
vous l'aurez compris les régions ne font
pas partie du dispositif c'est le hic
hervé morin dit vouloir organiser la
vaccination dans sa région mais il est
probable qu'il ne puisse pas le faire
voilà donc une belle annonce qui en
réalité a peu de chances d'aboutir
mais cette annonce a au moins un mérite
montrer le volontarisme
certes à peu de risque ici un des
collectivités locales
se plaignent d'être les oubliés de la
stratégie vaccinale et dire
politiquement qu'on est pour le vaccin
et qu'on incite ses citoyens à se faire
vacciner
vous savez depuis quelques jours une
blague circule en allemagne sur une
discussion entre un français et un
gouvernement
ah non moi hors de question que je me
fasse vacciner
de toute façon vous n'y avez pas droit
lui répond le gouvernement quoi je n'y
ai pas droit
rendez moi mes droits vacciner mois la
voilà peut-être la stratégie
gouvernementale de vaccination
[Musique]
c'est déjà la fin de votre 7,8 week-end
merci de l'avoir suivi l'information
revient lundi à 18h dans le 7-8 journal
présenté par grégory canale et d'ici là
je souhaite une très bonne soirée et un
très bon week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]